People always like to ask me, what is it that
a producer does? I like to reply, I produce.
And that doesn't mean I just pay for it,
though I do. I'm the one who gives birth to
it all. It's what I've always wanted to do.
It's what I've always done.
Well tell him, if he can't write a song that sounds like
Andrew Lloyd Webber, I'll call someone else.
I'll call Andy fucking Weber, That's who, Carl.
Ma'am, we're going to need you to push now.
I got to go. Just get it done. Hey.
I've won nine Tonys.
I've given birth to 34 Broadway shows.
But if someone asks me what my favorite thing
I've ever made is, Mamma mia! Hands down,
changed the trajectory of my whole career.
That's a joke.
Producers can be funny. People don't realize
that.
I'm your mommy. I'll protect you for the
rest of your life.
Hey, Carl, tell him the song should be called
The Rest of Your Life.
It's about a parent imagining a life for
their child.
The thing no one tells you when
you first start is how rewarding producing
can be. Or...
How dangerous.
But I should surprise- I know who you are.
This is so incredibly exciting to be invited
into the inner sanctum. Like this. Watching
you three work.
I imagine it's like being inside that documentary.
Watching Paul McCartney write Get back.
Yeah. That's why they call us the Rolling
Stones of true crime.
No, it's the-
Beatles, I was kidding.
And thank you for yesterday for stopping me
from pleading guilty to Ben's murder.
Well, we know that you were just trying to
protect Dickie, your son.
And thank you for bailing me out.
I paid your bail.
Yes, but when they say they didn't take Amex,
I hope you find your visa.
Anything for you, Mi amore. My peapod.
My little cuddle pops.
Oh-
Is this what this looks like?
You don't call Tobert cuddle pups.
I have a hard enough time calling him
Tobert.
The documentary guy. Are you and he?
Oh, nice.
Thanks, I know. Right?
So, are we sure about Donna?
On opening night? Donna got her hands on an
early review, and it was a pan, a massacre.
The harshest review in the history.
I have had, like, six heart attacks this
season, Charles. Can we move past the shitty
review and just recap what we know?
Okay, so Donna can't let her son's first show
be a bomb due to Ben, so she shreds the
review, finds the rat poison, makes a
poisonous cookie, and gives it to him.
A cookie she knows that he can't resist due to
his deep-seated eating disorder.
And in fact it was my unhealthy relationship to dips that
helped us crack it.
Leave me alone. I'm happy.
I'll get help.
But the poison didn't kill Ben, so Donna
takes things a step further. She pushes him
down the elevator shaft at Oliver's after
party.
Admittedly, it's a pretty drastic step for
her. She had to have been-
sick.
She is sick.
And if she only has a limited amount
of time to ensure her son's future, I tell
you, a mother will do almost anything.
It's good, but it's thin. We don't have
anything tying Donna to the push. We need a
confession on tape.
It's what we do.
And on opening night.
Okay, let's go over the plan. Let's start
with the bouquet of flowers.
Can we tweak these?
Yeah, I did these really fast.
The Oliver lines on card three, I think I
should take them.
You don't think I can say those?
Oh, no, you could, but I think I can do more
with it.
In what way?
How could you do.
Well, just it needs to be so real and so
believable. And I have a little more
experience at it.
Is it always like this?
This is us on fire.
Hey.
Do you know when you're going to tell Dickie?
I just want to get through opening night, and
then I'm going to tell him right afterwards.
Oh, yay!
That was a weird thing to fist bump on.
Yeah, it was odd.
Oh, Dickie showed me something when he came
to visit me after my arrest, I have it.
You know what? I think we should lose all
your lines on card nine. I mean, if we want
Donna to confess before curtain, we need
cuts, and you tend to milk your stuff.
Me? Milk my stuff?
Oh, that's right, that's what I do. Yep, I
milk everything. Oh, look at me. Oh, I'm
milking bossy the cow. Milk, milk, milk. Oh,
look at all the milk I'm getting.
Okay, you got a point.
Dickie was worried that this might implicate
me, but might this tie Donna to the push?
What? Did I do good?